do you guys have any any of you have a
spooky-looking story how
do an improv story we started you start
it will do a sentence at a time go lake
house home in the Catskills in New York
upstate sort of market go gave me a lot
of information to work with the legs
very detailed scenario bring it home so
so in this lake house in upstate New
York in the Catskills Catskills
Catskills that's absolutely worth it
yeah no cat scales go ahead the
Catskills were where the cat scales
which are xylophones for cats and we we
didn't bring cats though with us so when
we heard the cat scales we knew we were
in trouble go we didn't have cats with
us but we can hear the cat scales and
with me and I forgot to mention that
Wade was there and was just like I can't
even handle the cat scales exist how are
we supposed to fight this and I was like
well you know what you know what the one
thing that cats are the most fearful of
right its Cool Ranch Doritos and weight
always has like six bags of Cool Ranch
Doritos when we go on vacation together
so I went into Wade's trunk that he
carries its got like goofy stickers all
over it it's like one of those it's like
a Harry Potter trunk and he's got a wad
in there too so I went in there and I
got I got like three of the six bags of
Cool Ranch Doritos and I got him out and
I was like let's just sprinkle these on
all the window sills and keyboards in
the house and that'll keep the cat's
away that are playing those cat scales
and I forget what happened next I
remember things okay good thank God
I just tasted say some words mark that
was one sentence so then so then after
we ran out of Cool Ranch Doritos we
thought we were safe in the Catskills
and we thought that we were safe but
unfortunately they weren't actually cats
they were we're cats people that turn
into cats under the light of the full
moon and they are not allergic to Cool
Ranch Doritos so Wayde donned his Harry
Potter garb and put on his robe and then
took his wand out and ran into the room
would screaming casting Harry Potter's
Bell pious typists as he blasted the
we're cats away with his wand juice and
go unfortunately that's only weights
version of the story and what actually
happened was he ran he ran into the
woods he ran to the woods wearing his
Harry Potter stuff like screaming P -
flailing his wand around really girly
with his female hands and and the cat
just ate him because Harry Potter's not
real and we didn't know that but what
can you do so we lost Wade and then it
was just marking me I forgot to mention
that mark was there I was there he was
just quietly sitting in the background
like he does and Mark hopped up and was
like [ __ ]
we're cats go ahead mark okay so I said
[ __ ] where cats because I hate them
goddamn they're the worst and I didn't
know what to do but I reached into
Wade's trunk and deep down in the bottom
there was this wet bag in there and I
pulled it out and it was really gross
because when I opened it up it was just
filled with I didn't know what it was so
I handed it to Bob and I told him that
this was the secret ingredient to
killing all the we're cats and he
believed me so this is what happened
next
yeah well so mark handed me this
that I instantly realized as obviously
being weights P code and I really bring
this whole thing full circle didn't I
yeah so I took weights peacoat and I put
it on and I just was like you know what
you guys ate Wade and marks not gonna do
[ __ ] he's just gonna sit back there on
Twitter on a stupid iPhone and do
anything and I just ran out into the
woods and I beat the [ __ ] out of those
[ __ ] werecats
I punched them all in there people he
cat like faces and Edie Wade the maids
number two and I and Wade was never
heard from again okay unfortunately that
was just Bob side of the story what
really happened Bob put on the pea coat
he loved it so much and then ran out to
join the werecats and the werecats
smelled the pea coat and then claimed
him as one of them and they made him
their king and they made him king of the
werecats so and that's a story of how I
became king of the werecats
yes that's what happened happy Halloween
you